نعم في الواقع هنالك شبه تاكيد بان
الاستهداف هو عبر مسيره اسرائيليه اطلقت
الصواريخ باتجاه باتجاه احد المقرات
التابعه لحركه حماس في الضحيه الجنوبيه
للبنان في المطقه القريبه من المشرفيه
وبالتالي الان التعامل يتم بشكل واضح من
قبل كافه الاطراف المعنيه بمحور المقاومه
بان الاستهداف هو استهداف اسرائيلي مباشر
عبر طائره مسيره ادى الى استشهاد صالح
العاروري واثنين من قاده القسام و بالتالي
انطلاقا من هذا المعطى الميداني المباشر
يمكن الحديث عن كل التطورات الاخرى التي
تتقاطع عن ان لبنان امام امتحان مختلف
اعتبارا من هذه اللحظه من اللحظه التي جرى
اغتيال صالح العاروري فيها وبالتالي اليوم
كما اشرت خديجه ننتظر غدا الخطاب خطاب
الامين العام لحزب الله وما سيحمله هذا
الخطاب الذي كان مبرمجا سابقا والان
سننتظر ما سيحمله غدا وكيف كفيه التعامل
والتعاطي مع هذا الاغتيال وماذا سيكون
هناك دعيني دعيني اشير الان الى بيان صدر
عن رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه
الذي دان هذا الانفجار وهنا انقل من
البيان قال نقاطي ان هذا الانفجار جريمه
اسرائيليه جديده تهدف حكما الى ادخال
لبنان في مرحله جديده من المواجهات بعد
الاعتداءات اليوميه في الجنوب والتي تؤدي
الى سقوط الشهداء والجرحى وبالتالي هنا
خديجه كلام رئيس حكومه تصيف الاعمال في
لبنان واضح بان هذا الانفجار يهدف الى
ادخال لبنان مرحله جديده وهو يستكمل ويقول
بان هذا الانفجار هو حكما توريط للبنان
ورد واضح على المساعي التي نقوم بها
لابعاد شبح الحرب الدائره في غزه عن لبنان
وايضا يطالب نقاطي الدول المعنيه بالضغط
على اسرائيل ويحذر من من كل هذه السياسات
المتمادي التي تقوم بها ويذكر بطبيعه
الحال بالتزام لبنان القرار 1701 وبالتالي
من هنا من خلال هذا الكلام خديجه الصادر
عن رئيس الحكومه اللبنانيه يمكن ان نستشرف
بان منسوب القلق يرتفع رئيس الحكومه يتحدث
عن ان اسرائيل تسعى من خلال اغتيال
العاروري الى ادخال لبنان في مرحله جديده
من المواجهات وبالتالي كل الكلام التحليلي
السابق يمكن الان ان يرتكز الى هذا الكلام
الرسم والذي بدا يتواتر ويصدر عن مسؤولين
اللبنانيين والذين يعتبرون بان ما تقوم به
اسرائيل حاليا من خلال هذا الاغتيال انما
هو سعي مباشر لجر لبنان الى مواجهه والى
مرحله جديده وتحديدا هذا ما يمكن الان ان
نستشفه من خلال الكلام الرسمي وايضا من
خلال كل الخبره السابقه في كيفيه تعامل
حزب الله مع هكذا تطورات وايضا بالاضافه
الى الت التحذيرات السابقه من قبل الامين
العام للحزب خديجه هذا الاغتيال لن يمر
مرور الكرام في لبنان على كافه المستويات
التعامل معه سيكون مختلفا وهنا يمكن القول
بان لبنان اذاء مفترض فيطرق الجبهه
الجنوبيه تحديدا امام مفترق طرق كبير سبق
واشرنا بان امتحان الرد هو لحزب الله وس
سنرى غدا كيف سيتعامل الامين العام لحزب
الله مع هذا الامر ما هو الموقف الذي
سيضعه انطلاقا مما كان قد حذره ووضع
الخطوط الحمراء سابقا كيف سيتم التعامل
وهنا اعود مجددا الى الميدان خديجه رصدنا
خلال الايام العشره الماضيه تغيرا فعليا
في كيفيه قيام حزب الله بتنفيذ عملياته
اذا ما كان الشهر الاول او
الشهرين في بدايه المواجهات تقوم على ما
كان يعرف بتعمي المواقع اسرائيليه
واستهداف عواميد الارسال واجهزه الارسال
وما الى ذلك ولكن اعتبارا من مطلع الشهر
الماضي تغيرت المعطيات وهذا الامر رصدناه
على مستويين المستوى الاول بطبيعه الاسلحه
نوعا وكما نعم ماذا نبقى معنا من خل المب
ماذا نبقى معنا جوني موجود